wahnsinn es ist wirklich möglich wie in
einem science fiction nissan hat ein
system vorgestellt das ermöglichen soll
autos mit gedanken zu steuern
und es ist nahezu serienreifen ranger
technology heißt die neue technologie
wie das funktionieren soll jetzt in
klick zum science fiction herzlich
willkommen
über das steuern eines flugzeugs mit
gedanken haben wir ja hier schon mal
berichtet aber dass jetzt bei nissan ist
ein ganz anderer schnack nochmal zum
flugzeug
statt mit einem steuerknüppel ist es mit
einer haube möglich flugzeuge eben nur
mit gedanken zu steuern ein
steuerknüppel ist nicht mehr nötig
allein die hirnströme steuern das
flugzeug im flugsimulator
durch das direkte feedback also dadurch
dass die piloten sofort sehen was ihre
gedanken bewirken ist die steuerung
bereits mit relativ großer präzision
möglich mit hilfe von
elektroenzephalografie elektroden werden
die befehle gegeben normalerweise werden
diese elektroden eingesetzt um in der
forschung aktivitäten in bestimmten
hirnregionen zu messen oder auch in der
medizin um störungen im gehirn
aufzuspüren aber dass ein gedanke damit
entschlüsselt werden könnte
das war bisher noch nicht möglich und
jetzt scheint es zu gehen zumindest
rechts und links können damit als
befehle gemessen werden allerdings so
beruhigen die forscher wirkliche
gedanken können so nicht gelesen werden
allerdings ist der algorithmus der an
der technischen universität münchen
entwickelt wurde so ausgefeilt dass er
die beiden anweisungen rechts und links
aus den hirnen signalen auslesen werden
hier oben links im bild ist zu erkennen
wie stark die befehle im gehirn gegeben
werden und dann zur steuerung verwendet
werden die genauigkeit ist zwar schon
ziemlich beachtlich aber noch nicht so
hoch wie bei einem steuerknüppel
das liegt auch daran dass die
rückkopplung der kräfte die an einem
steuerknüppel anliegen fehlt es fehlt
ein gegendruck wie an der steuerung
eines flugzeugs wie er da zu spüren ist
jetzt hat nissan das verfahren aber
deutlich präzisiert und praxistauglich
gemacht dabei hat der autohersteller
eine vorstufe gefunden die einfach aber
genial ist die signale werden dabei
nicht zum kompletten stollen benutzt
sondern die technik lernt vom fahrer
oder der fahrerin was vor einem ereignis
im gehirn passiert dabei sehen die
elektroenzephalografie elektronen auf
viel eleganter aus sie lesen dann
tatsächlich gedanken und zwar nicht nur
rechts und links sondern auch bremsen
lenken gas geben und so weiter da das
gehirn die befehle millisekunden vor der
eigentlichen handlung gibt kann das
fahrzeug jetzt auch auf diese befehle
millisekunden vorher reagiert
erschrecke ich mich also mit eine
notbremsung machen weil ein unfall droht
weis das fahrzeug etwas früher bescheid
und kann sich schon darauf vorbereiten
genau so bei allen anderen funktionen
die fahrerin oder der fahrer sollen
davon überhaupt nichts merken außer dass
alles vielleicht einen hauch schneller
gehen ich finde das ja teilweise bei
modernen autos mit ziemliche katastrophe
die brauchen teilweise so eine
gedenksekunde wenn man aufs gas tritt
bis es dann wirklich losgeht mit der
neuen technologie soll das der
vergangenheit angehören also dann haben
wir wieder autos wie früher die sofort
wirken wie losgegangen sind weiter
gedacht hat dass aber ihre konsequenzen
das hat sich ja schon mal ein flugzeug
thema überlegt wenn wir wirklich in der
lage wären unsere umgebung dann mit
gedanken zu steuern weil dahin kann sich
das eher entwickeln würde sich alles
dramatisch verändern griffe schalter
knöpfe alles würde verschwinden ja weil
man es ja mit gedanken steuern kann und
wenn dann noch die anzeigen von
temperaturen geschwindigkeiten und so
weiter in eine brille oder in
kontaktlinsen banner also dort
eingespielt werden
dann stehen wir vor einer umfassenden
verwandlung der wirklichkeit denn dann
wird die realität erst durch die
zusätzliche virtuelle realität die
argumente tea komplett ist wenn ich im
auto die geschwindigkeit in einer brille
oder in den kontaktlinsen eingespielt
sie kann ich es mit meinen gedanken
steuern und auch meine gedanken gehören
dann zu dieser realität sie werden
unmittelbar wirklichkeit wenn ich dem
auto befehle zum beispiel schneller zu
fahren und das ist wirklich science
fiction und wirklich ein bisschen
verrückt das verschmelzen von virtueller
und realer realität wenn er kein video
zu diesem thema und auch zu allen
anderen themen verpassen wollt dann wird
mir hier ein abo aufs auge und vergesse
nicht den genau auf die glocke nur dann
werdet ihr auch immer über neue videos
informiert hier geht es weiter mit dem
flugzeug video natürlich dafür
draufklicken gedanken steuern flugzeug
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran